[Music]
and it's just a game news it's never
just a game it's never just a game it's
always real you need some [ __ ] to say
Geo
Thank You red bull do you have a
complimented you didn't hear her what I
didn't hear it she was just so stuck on
being mean I wasn't I remember I said
this is what a JK ladies podcast would
sound like you're so [ __ ] hot no
you're [ __ ] hey you didn't hear me
but I said your [ __ ] boobs real
[ __ ] around
I like the balls on your ears thank you
without the color of the veins in your
face the veins veins making up [ __ ]
right now I like your poor is healing
real tight today well this is submitted
by McDonald's Nosed Amalia King but they
also don't Gina that's the man right
here did you go to the McDonald's oven
or do they send that to you they sent it
to me wait those are real I thought you
got her a brayer so no it's not all swag
are you jelly kind of I don't even I
could buy it
you can't cuz I'm like in and out you
have to buy this way right yeah it has
to be given to you man you have to be
worthy of their acknowledgment all you
got to do is intercept the tweet from
Gina they will be will message you what
kind of King does his own intro that's
lame it's a [ __ ] trumpet we're
in the middle of hiring some musical
people right now I just can't find all
right no one could do it as good as I do
that's why I you know the hire process
is just like [ __ ] it I'll do it myself a
youth soccer referee is standing up
against unruly parents at sporting
events yes you're the worst people get
it is it the same time when that left
the twelve kids to being captured I
think they're talking about like soccer
parents thank that no need to freak out
they were just I came for nine days
she's crazy
that was hard
like on like your over-ear I was
teaching them survival skills they got
out way he's all good jump chicken
Spring Break so why are these soccer
moms acting like soccer hooligans it's
not just mom it's dad that's me so why
are they acting like soccer hooligans on
a children's game they're losers is it a
soccer game though baby going on there
life
yeah they compensate for what they're
overcompensating for what they belong on
in life yeah it's not just soccer it's
like sports like any sports that have a
referee I see it all the time
oh really what games are you watching no
toys to play and what does it cost pet
bag or just that the athlete what he
wasn't actually playing a sport so I
didn't play a sport okay I watched a lot
of sports being so I see the parents
come and they're yelling at the referee
all the time and they would always blood
oh you [ __ ] blind [ __ ] did
you shut up foul so they're like the
game police all the time yeah the game
hoechlin I was jealous because I always
wanted my parents to do that for me but
they're musicians right so I was hoping
out a recital don't be like hell the
[ __ ] again and they start freaking like
raising their hands up like lighters and
all that [ __ ] but that never happened it
was just this you know you know I
imagine these are the kind of dads you
know exactly they look like they have
shorts polo polo shirt on the glasses
the sunglasses in the back of their head
a Bluetooth and they have the velcro
sandals sandals or the high socks like
they have these socks all the way pulled
up I have their own whistle yeah yeah
yeah so I'm going to show you guys a
video clip of some parents taking these
games a little too serious the first one
is where the parents are fighting I hope
I'm not one of those parents
oh what a great example three these
people have dodge Rams oh come on I got
a teen referee what does she do hit up
kick a ball
yeah like really aggressively
oh no that's uh is it for just one team
no it's just across the pins epidemic
polo shirt kids that are trying to learn
the skill of being a referee and yet
they're in the middle of a cesspool of
verbal insults by adults it's like if
the hate comments came alive in your
comment section oh I want to join that
group yeah he offers $100 for videos of
parents berating referees a group called
off field I'll look at it again I went
to my friends a hockey game one time I
thanked and then his mom was super
supportive she was just like oh man
that's so good and then I was watching
like you suck today cuz he wasn't making
any of the shots and I was like to him
dude that's so cool cuz if I suck my mom
would just tell me that today you sucked
and you don't eat tonight no food for
you that's pretty far but yeah she
wouldn't church is like you only get a
chair or whatever if you did it good I'm
like damn that's dull yeah there's this
one time it wasn't it wasn't a
children's thing but I was a ring girl
for an MMA fight
and there's this guy fighting and his
wife was in the back and part of my
language but she was yelling she was
like this fat white [ __ ] right like she
looked like she came she rolled out of
the trailer into this [ __ ] ring and
part of my language she goes yeah kill
that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll just
like wow creaming it like kill it kill
him and I'm just sitting there like what
the [ __ ] is going on we're in the face
did she get kicked out no no no this is
an underground fight no this was like
kinky king of the cage she like MMA
and I'm sitting there like just like
glarey well I can't do thing cuz I got
hired to be a ring girl can be
unprofessional [ __ ] what's round right
u-233
oh you just come out with your sign
you're like you're like this but in your
mind you're like oh my god the [ __ ]
language crazy when they cheer for [ __ ]
clip that and then put it at a condo
yeah that's true
no don't suggest that now people are
getting ideas show them this video
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you can't even say [ __ ]
like when you're quoting other people
anymore you got a sense of that [ __ ]
that no you this that's what you
observed and that's what you're
repeating yeah even like there was this
one time I was reading a thing I was
reading a direct quote and I was like I
can't even do that anyway this coach
here from Tulsa he started this
organization called stop stop which
stands for stop tormenting officials
permanently and so whoever what a jobber
leagues join this right here they post
up signs to remind parents like calm the
[ __ ] down calm down don't take it so
seriously because I feel like there's a
sportsman level of it's it's a part of
the sport right like when you're a crowd
you're just like oh come on man that was
totally not a fun and you're just saying
[ __ ] I think that's a part of the game
but when you start getting out of
control and you really internalize that
[ __ ] that's weird
yeah that's [ __ ] they're saying that
a lot of these parents they take it so
[ __ ] serious like cuz they swear that
they're they spend so much money on like
their six-year-old to get like private
coaching like the to be in the best
leagues to whatever like they're just
trying to make sure that they're gonna
grow up to be professionals and so
that's why they take it so serious and
then cuz of ruining their kids record or
something some thing I mean but there's
a little Catholic ain't nobody looking
at that six-year-old t-ball record right
kids like three years old he does
there's no where he is right now
yeah there's kids out there they're just
like oh he's big his boogers he's eating
in now filled that was actually Isaac
here's a good
you're screaming at the umpire
get out of there he's embarrassing me
you always have like untuck oversized
shirts like half of it is untucked and
it's oversized or like they're running
toward the wrong way or like I love that
especially basketball games cuz they
travel and then they dribble well yeah
that's right
oh he also played basketball yeah I
always thought I was so funny when he
was thick as his hands all the way in
his pocket his pockets are so huge
compared to like just tiny little body
where if you always end up in the front
I'm like what do you looks wrong but
yeah it's so cute they're so lost when
they they just start sitting down Oh
tired no one claimed that's the best
thing you have the other kids are
complete opposite there's a image and
they're [ __ ] pros they're like whoa
it's those people's parents exactly yeah
yeah it's like they're bored they don't
have anything I mean must be nice but
that's like the biggest thing that
you're concerned about it's it's so
embarrassing you imagine being that kid
your mom's just like Oh again they talk
about in this article that there was as
one instance where this coach made that
the child go up to their parent and tell
him to stop like stop you have to tell
the child to do that the referee made
the child go up to the parent their
parent that was screaming at the referee
to stop so it was humiliating for the
child yeah for the parent and there were
other parents around that they were like
oh I'm so glad they did that the parents
are putting their pride whatever they
want before the child of those
beauty-pageant much yeah exactly like
honey shake your titties look he's she's
three what the [ __ ] are you doing that's
weird
weirdest [ __ ] is she's dancing along
with them it's [ __ ] creepy that's
like that one grandpa one
remember when he toured around the
country with his grandkid and then he
was she was bad grandpa I think the
Jackass one yeah yeah and then it was a
little boy and then he went like as a
beauty pageant girl yeah there was a
dude that was on the news his
stepdaughter or daughter grew up to be a
porn star
and he was her manager and he was like
yeah when she was like 13 I knew she was
gonna grow up to be hot so like
sometimes he waxes her for her yeah it's
it's [ __ ] creepy issue with the
manager if the dad dad the dad was
matter is the manager she knew was Azmi
hot I think it was I don't remember
those biological that's kind of weird
that's very weird either way would it be
weird if they were both hot and he had
no direct relationship to her like in
that way that's also very weird just any
adult that's like this sir has his own
business
I wouldn't even but then he wouldn't be
managing yeah exactly
I saw I mean I saw oh this is weird that
a 13-month game why she became an adult
right yeah she does porn and he manages
her I don't know if that's weird
actually what if he waxes like the
bikini wax or whatever like he's just
getting it it's like makeup do makeup
but he's a professional actor just her
doing porn yeah his own daughter and he
even said well I guess it's weird for us
[Music]